[Musique]
voir les enfants excusez-moi pas trop je
descends très vite je suis impatient de
voir juliette à hier elle était
tellement triste que cornichons les
laisser
je vais voir si elle se console ma
petite seule europe hop hop hop hop hop
on peut
manger
bon soir les enfants
bonsoir
rejoint au tarif bien au long que se
passe-t-il
vous n'êtes pas encore des abus ce n'est
pas sérieux
c'est du jamais on apprenait juliette 1
et elle nous a fait courir
elle vole alors elle va très vite et
nous manquons après je connais ça
alors julien tu as tu encore été
qu'aucune
[Musique]
et maintenant elles revivent de manger
bon allez vous déshabiller je m'en
occupe
je vais chez
une petite cuillère
liotta pour faire plaisir à nounours
oh non non nicolas et pimprenelle on ne
se couche pas billets voyons au ses
enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un long bain julietta encore un peu de
ce délicieux bifteck pour hibou et si tu
es gentille demain je te ferai une
surprise là
tu vois on s'est même là d'éléments dans
ces très bien aller vite au lit je
viendrai atteindre votre l'humain animal
nous
ans est sacré julietta oui et quand elle
s'est perchée tout au delà j'ai bien cru
que redescendre et j'appelle les camps
d'al est d'aller sur l'épaule des gardes
à vue vers la ville et bien sacré
juliette a à manger mais elle s'endort
[Musique]
je lui ai promis une surprise pour
demain et je vous raconterai une belle
histoire de philippe seguin allons on
dormait vous vite
c'est un liner
pas donné
à dallas
[Musique]
le temps que cornichons revienne cette
petite jugé talent tellement triste
patron demain je lui raconterai une
histoire très bonne idée nounours allons
en route la nuit des enfants fait de pur
[Musique]
vous